aber wir wollen auch sprechen über den
mann den man da jetzt hinter mir sieht
den hamburger innensenator andy grote
über den haben wir gestern hier schon
gesprochen aber der fall das sogenannte
pimmel gate wird immer spektakulärer wer
halt noch mal ganz kurz fest andy grote
hatte sich aufgeregt über eine party in
corona zeiten und gesagt so kann das
aber nicht gehen problem er hatte selber
eine gefeiert mit 30 jungs hatte er
gefeiert dass er weiter im senat wo
bleiben durfte erinnern wir uns auch
noch mal andy grote das ist der mann der
zum beispiel der hamburger jenischpark
feiern die schüler mit polizeiautos so
jagen lassen hat dass sie fast ums leben
gekommen werden dieser mann hat sich
bewährt und daraufhin hat er auf twitter
geschrieben unter 1 seiner tweets himmel
was passierte vorgestern morgen 6 uhr
klingelte es an der tür polizei sechs
leute die andy grote da die diesen
herren da besuchen wollten und das handy
sicherstellen wollten für mich ist dass
wir gesagt habe eine absurde form von
doppelmoral erstens andy grote hat
selber die partys gefeiert über die er
sich dann aufgeregt hat zweitens wenn
man jetzt für das wort pimmel die
polizei schickt dann muss man vermutlich
jeden tag die polizei in jede erster
oder zweiter klasse schicken und
drittens und darüber habe ich gestern
nachgedacht ein fall der mich in berlin
bewegt ein sehr prominentes clan
mitglied ali abou chaker wird bei einer
schießerei mit einer machete auf der
straße gefilmt und spaziert frei auf den
straßen rom irgendwo fragen sich normale
menschen schon noch mal was muss ich
eigentlich machen damit dann die polizei
kommt das kleinste vergehen wenn ich im
himmel sein scheint zu erreichen aber
wenn ich als hoch dekorierte sklaven
mitglied in eine schießerei verwickelt
bin und mit einer machete über die
straße laufen dann passiert offenbar
nehmen wir haben andy grote dazu
befragen das hat er uns gesagt
in diesem fall die staatsanwaltschaft
das entschieden da eine eine
hausdurchsuchung zu veranlassen und
ja das ist eine autonome entscheidung es
muss nur allen klar sein dass wenn wir
wollen dass solche taten verfolgt werden
konsequent verfolgt werden beleidigungen
hass im netz auch erfolgreich verfolgt
wird dann gehören dazu auch
hausdurchsuchungen die brauchen wir ganz
regelhaft um das dann auch beweissicher
als die anklage vor gericht zu bringen
auch wenn es halt nur eine beleidigung
ist der solche konsequentes handeln
würden sich andere beleidigungs opfer
natürlich auch wünschen egoyan
insbesondere auch frauen die immer
wieder anzeigen hat nichts passiert und
man muss auch einfach sagen dass wenn
ich mich entscheide als politiker auf
twitter zu gehen dann muss ich halt so
zu sagen ich sag das mal so salopp
kümmel fest sein ja also dass es da noch
wirklich unterschwelligen bereich von
dem was auf twitter passiert da kann man
sagen ist das hier zu einer verrohung
der gesellschaft ich würde sagen da
sprechen wir halt wirklich über das was
ich erst und zweitklässler an den kopf
werfen wenn andy grote sich davon schon
beleidigt fühlt und dafür dann schon die
polizei morgens hausdurchsuchungen macht
für dieses wort dann sollte man den
innensenator der übrigens für den
g20-gipfel verantwortlich war als
einfach die stadt hat brennen lassen
fragen ob bei ihm da nicht die maßstäbe
ganz massiv verrutscht sind
[Musik]